[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the public
space today we talk about space-time and
undeniable concepts since its present in
every physical equations that exist it
determines the distance between us
determines our the way we are impacted
by gravity by electricity but this bill
gate defer will ask him tonight I don't
matter how are you doing I'm doing good
as a reminder to our crowd you can join
us on entropy if you have questions for
us tonight the survey of the night is do
you agree with Bill about space-time so
we'll see what he thinks of it it tends
to be a subversive scientist it tends to
be questioning the the concepts what
about space-time bill does it exist well
in order to know whether space-time God
or a leprechaun exists you know we have
to define the word exist and the word
exist has never been defined the last
10,000 years as far as I'm concerned you
look it up what you find is a synonym
you find being you find to be you find
living you find reality you find all
these synonyms and when you look at
those words they just say exist so we
don't have a definition today and you
don't have to take my word for it you
can go to the stanford encyclopedia of
philosophy you can go to the internet
encyclopedia philosophy you can go to
any of these and you won't find a
definition which you will find is what
all the philosophers throughout history
said about exists and today we don't
have a solid definition anywhere i
define exists very precisely very
concisely and i'm saying that regularly
right that you can use it consistently
scientifically rationally and you find
it saying that it's an object that has
location this the synthesis for the
definition is physical presence that
means an object that has location if god
wants to exist if space-time wants to
exist all it's got to do
is be an object first a physical object
a thing and then it's got to have
distance between you know between God's
chest in my chest in other words he's
got to have location and I don't care if
God wants to hide in the twenty-sixth I
mentioned there should be a straight
line connecting his chest with my chest
and despite mission not because I
believe or disbelieve so then it seems
that space exists because location
requires special coordinates doesn't it
space is not a physical object the first
criterion for existence is this has to
be an object it can't be a concept love
cannot be said to exist in physics in
science love can be said to exist
in ordinary speech we can say all love
exists you know very poetic it has no
meaning in science in science only
objects can be said to exist and the way
we figure this out the best way to
imagine this is let's kill all observers
let's kill all life in the universe what
remains is what exists all right so
let's get started on this train so you
have brought us a couple of pictures to
illustrate the concept what happens if
we start considering space-time as
something that doesn't exist but that is
a concept I mean I don't take issue with
this it's just a special definition of
exist where does that bring us to the
point where mathematical physics has
reasons I would say at least since the
17th century scientific revolution has
gone more into concepts and less into
objects physics is about objects physics
cannot be done without an object you
have to have a thing for that you have
to define what an object is what a thing
is and what mathematical physics has
taken science you know they went on a
tangent it took us along a road that
leads us to introduce concepts as
physical objects you'll hear a statement
or a phrase such as
transfer of energy moving a mass bending
of time stretching a field and there are
no such physical objects those are all
mathematical concepts and not only have
we brought these concepts into science
as physical objects but now we say
further that they exist because you know
they say well it does a magnet have a
magnetic field but what is a field
well they don't worry about that it's a
mathematical concept but suddenly the
field is not only a physical object but
it also exists and we have to get into
the language at this point because you
know these people are essentially
introducing objects concepts as physical
objects and then compelling them to
exist and that's the it's the physical
interpretation that we are receiving
okay well we can categorize the world
and objects and concepts but that being
said there is such a thing as the
differential effect of gravity based on
distance you agree with this right Oh
equation I fall down - so the soda
gravity okay it doesn't exist as an
object but it exists as a relation
between two things okay agree with that
but I'll go further now say that it's
not only a relation because that would
be a mathematical perspective I'm gonna
say from a physical perspective there
have better be something an unseen
intangible object that serves as
mediator that causes gravity and that's
what a physicist has to figure out what
it what is it that produces gravity what
causes gravity there has to be a
physical object otherwise we're
introducing spirits in there all right
so let's get started on the images you
introduce the concept of simultaneity in
this training example what do we see
here well well this is how
Relativity began at the beginning of the
20th century essentially not only
Einstein but even other people you know
like him
Minkowski and and others they came up
with this notion of relativity saying
that they put the observer at the center
of the of the action and they said it's
what the observer perceives and in this
case what we see as a train it's being
hit in the front side by a lightning
bolt and also in the back if if the
lightning bolt hits front and back at
the same time a person that's standing
in the like that when they're standing
in the platform will see those two
lightning bolts hit at the same time
because he's equidistant from both front
and back of the Train
however a passenger on the train would
see it differently would have the front
side of the lightning bolt hit the front
side get to his eyes faster than one in
the back side because he's moving in the
direction of the lightning bolt and so
what I was saying with this and others
as well is that it's all relative it's a
this simultaneity that the passenger
that the observer on the platform
observes that's a question of relativity
because the person who's moving on the
train seems sees something different and
therefore measures something different
okay and so from this they extrapolated
that you know some of these variables
are not some are variables and some are
not variables for example what Einstein
came up with is that light travels at a
fixed speed independent of the movement
of the observer or the sorry of the
source but then each individual measures
then the other factors as variables time
right time is what it becomes a variable
and distance
those become variables and it's a
belated later to general relativity they
generalize the theory and eventually we
end up with this concept known as
space-time which is SMC for a four
coordinate system as they call it and
I'm saying it's not even coordinate or
dimensions or vectors has nothing to do
with the dimensions coordinates and
vectors of physics it only has to do
with number lines yes it is a number
line the space-time and the space-time
can be bent which is the only way we can
reconcile I guess these observer a
different observers seeing different
things from the universe you have to
think that the train gets smaller as it
advances faster and that time bends also
yeah but one interesting part of that is
that the Train
Corie Reinstein right and mathematical
physics still still stands behind that
the Train cannot travel exactly at the
speed of light you know you don't want
to convert all that mass into just
energy you know and so the issue is
that's an equation and they don't want
that zero in an equation you know where
the train goes so fast that you have
velocity of light over velocity of light
essentially you know one so the Train
can only travel slightly less than the
velocity of light and therefore it can
shrink as one as much as you want
right but never down to zero and the
question is why did they go to that zero
because you know that means the Train
disappears but if it can travel at the
speed of light which means that now how
do we get it back if it disappeared so
so it's a I think it's ad hoc to say
that we cannot travel at the speed of
light and that's when your mathematical
in that's how that's only an equation
okay now there's thing the reason to
have there's no reason for to say that
something cannot travel at the speed of
light other than the fact that it goes
completely into energy
it shrinks completely to zero to zero
volume and then now how do we get it
back yeah that being said do you
recognize for example that there is an
increasing amount of energy to increase
your speed as you approach the speed of
life yeah
but again those are mathematical
concepts keep that in mind all we're
saying is we have used the word energy
the word mass or time to designate
certain concepts and they make sense in
mathematics the problem is now
interpreting that from a physical point
of view that's where I come in I'm
saying that none of these people are
giving us rational explanations for
their equations so I don't I'm not
disagreeing with the equations I have no
problem with equations because I'm not
interested in that I want them to tell
me how the universe works I'm gonna know
how gravity works I want to know how
magnetism works and they cannot come to
me and say look the way gravity works
though the reason the earth doesn't fly
out of the solar system is there's a
depression created by the Sun in
space-time they cannot tell me that
because space-time is not a physical
object it's a mathematical concept it
cannot serve as a wall to the exit or
the leaving of our planet out of the
solar system it cannot block the escape
of the of the earth because it's a
concept so the the physical
interpretation that Einstein gives to
his equation that's where we have a
little bit of a difference all right now
you have an illustration of the concept
of simultaneity a little bit like the
case of the lightning bolts on the train
but what are we seeing here objectivity
versus subjectivity mathematical
subjectivity versus physical objectivity
if we placed in Stein in a electric
chair right equidistant from the two
points right and we have a on the right
under a railroad track and we have a
train running through the railroad track
as soon as it touches the front wheel in
the back wheel cut
sleeeeep the wires connecting to you
know the railroad track - I inspected
his electric chair he should be fried if
he gets the two bolts at the same time
if I'm the other ham one bolt hits
Einstein before the other one he doesn't
get fried and the question is does
Einstein get fried or not and I'm saying
physics says that he will be fried
because we don't care about
interpretations we care about the
physics and the physics means that if
the front wheel in the back wheel touch
exactly at the same time not as measured
by anyone just physically they touch at
the same time both bolts will reach the
electric chair and there will be enough
voltage to fry Einstein if on the other
hand the front wheel reaches before the
black back wheel then obviously he will
not be fried because there's not enough
voltage and that's a physical issue now
that we're not an observer related
opinionated issues are you saying that
these statements are at odds with
general relativity the physics the
physical interpretation is the physical
interpretation of saying well what the
observer measure what did you observer
see you know what did what did he
perceive that doesn't end of the picture
of physics that that's that's subjective
we're not interested in subjectivity and
in physics who are interested in
objectivity complete objectivity for
that we remove the observer we remove
the mathematician and say what exists
out there independent of the observer
and you take issue with here because it
seems that the train will pass it will
send the electric shock if it's properly
configured to do so the electric shock
will arrive to Einstein it will be a
wave of electricity starting from the
negative side to the positive what is
the problem here are you saying that
there's a problem with the spatial
contraction of general relativity no I'm
saying that the issue of introducing an
observer a measure a person who's going
to do measurement and how he perceives
light electricity or whatever
it doesn't enter the picture in science
in science we're not interested in what
the observer perceives are measured what
we're saying is if we were to figure out
what the word simultaneous means under
from from the perspective of physics as
opposed to the perspective of
mathematics equations what we're saying
here is if the two lightning bolts
arrive at the chair simultaneously
physically the guy will be fried and if
they don't he won't be fried and that's
not what mathematics says mathematics
says well this observer saw it this way
the other guy saw it that way the guy in
the platform song coming at the same
time and the guy in the train saw one
come before the other that's not the
case in physics in physics it's one or
the other they can't have it both ways
and that that's why this issue of
relativity of how each one measured and
perceived the event plays no part
whatsoever and that's what the
mathematicians did for the entire 20th
century they introduced the observers
and measurement I mean I will take some
issues with this because it seems to me
that there is an observer here at sein
Stein the is observation is whether he
is receiving enough electricity to be
fried
but what general relativity tells us is
if this was happening at extremely high
speed which of course will not be
reachable by a coal powered train like
this one but suppose that the train was
going close to the speed of light the
person on the train would not see the
same sequence of events leading to the
explosion of Einstein but Einstein would
see it but the question is whether
whether the observer on the train or the
one on the platform what they perceive
what they see what they measure what
does that have to do with the fact that
two lightning bolts either hit
simultaneously and pry the guy or one
comes one bolt comes before the other
and they don't fry the guy it's a black
or white issue the if Einstein dies or
gets carbonized like and I show there
then they hit at the same time and if he
doesn't get carbonized they didn't hit
at the same time period we don't need
the opinions or perspectives or
measurements of observers
okay let's move on I'm not sure about
this but let's move on to the third the
third PowerPoint okay just to show you
there that this is people sometimes
expect Authority well here you have a
lot of authority you have steven
weinberg he's a noble prize he says I
don't think mathematics can never be
regarded as an explanation in itself for
anything and this has not always been
well understood in other words
mathematics can only describe
mathematics has no power to explain and
people don't always understand that they
think that we have explanations today
and we don't we have irrational
explanations for common phenomena and
then when you go in and try to talk to
the mathematicians try to present a
paper for example you know I have
submitted papers to science into nature
and it were rejected because they say
these are philosophical issues they
think that speculating about how the
universe actually works is not a concern
of physics they're only interested in
the mathematical description and so
people don't always understand that when
you go to Donald symonenko professor
emeritus at Lock Haven University
he says science doesn't explain science
describes so so you know the notion that
people have that physics is about
explaining they say this but it's all
it's all lip-service there is no
explanation no rational explanation when
you confront the mathematicians like I
have in the past they say oh but but
you're looking for causes and for for
mechanism yeah I said yeah that's what
I'm looking for the sample that's not
that's not fizzy that's not science
that's philosophy and so we got a
problem because I'm interested in the
physical interpretation I want to know
how magnet works and they're saying that
that's not part of physics yeah
definitely you are on a path of
mechanistic explanation of the physics
that we know of so Stephen Hawking was
he on that path too he wanted to
understand how the world works yeah but
apparently they they are not concerned
because
you know you get other statements that I
don't know if I've sent them to you but
people who say you know we can't
understand this universe there's no way
we're gonna understand it we science is
about researching about trying to study
the universe but never finding never
discovery in other words science is a
process of discovery and never one where
you reach a dead end and say okay now I
can explain how the universe works they
don't think in those terms they think
it's a ten ongoing process and obviously
it does create job security yes the ear
my wrists in Quebec was saying his name
was Sol he was saying as long as we paid
them for researching they have no
interest in finding I love that yeah
it's true I mean these people are only
interested in equations in describing
and here you have two girls who are
telling you you know we don't explain we
describe and people don't yet understand
that they think that we do understand
how the universe works in part because
of the fact that we have technology and
they say well the technology proves the
theory and that's not true that's where
the connection is is absolutely false
you know the fact that a computer works
does not prove that quantum is right the
fact that GPS works does not prove
general relativity or special relativity
it doesn't prove that you can bend time
which is the explanation that these
people give you it's also the
interpretation is irrational but they
but most people out there that these
people who don't look at it in deeply
enough they think that because we have
GPS that's proof that special relativity
is correct but what they're saying
essentially is that I mean if we if we
go by this what the mathematicians are
saying is we can bend time we can
stretch time bend it you know do all
kinds of things with time that's how
they accepts the physical interpretation
that is the theory and it and with the
other part is a description just a
mathematical description now it seems to
me that description is
something it is knowledge would you
agree with this we frown on the word
knowledge there is no such thing as
knowledge so all these words have to be
defined because people introduce the
word exist the word noun it's a word you
know all these words are introduced and
people think they know what they're
talking about now that I define it a
little different than leader all these
other people I define knowledge as the
ability to predict the outcome of an
experiment without error and there's no
such thing not even God can do that
without error that's how you increase
your threshold yeah but I'll give you an
example so put it in the right context
let's assume I drop a pen ten times and
ten times it falls to the floor so now
I'm going to improve my knowledge - you
say okay jf I'll bet you a million
dollars that when I let go of my pen now
it's gonna fall to the floor right to
the center of the earth right and it
turns out I let go the pen and it stays
in the air and I lost a million bucks -
jf karaoke yeah and I said what the hell
happened here and it turns out that you
tricked me you either had some air
pushing the air from below from the pen
from below or you had a couple magnets
on the side holding the pen in the air
you tricked me
so I did not know that the pen was gonna
fall to the floor I was guessing I had
an intelligent guest but based on my
experience but I did not know for a fact
that the pen was gonna fall to the floor
let alone man an asteroid comes and
destroys the earth and neither one of us
collects on the bed well it's see it
seems that our differences on the
definition of knowledge is absolute and
perfect versus and complete I recognize
the value of incomplete knowledge for
example if I have a a a coin and it
gives ads and tears but it gives ads
let's say 60% of the time I could say
this coin is loaded and that is
knowledge to me even if I can say on a
specific drop whether it will drop on
the head or the tail I have some
knowledge of it unless someone is
tricking you maybe God
maybe one of your buddies and he's using
magnets to do some funny thing in there
and then it's not that the but not that
the coin is loaded but that there's some
other phenomenon going on that you're
not aware of and again you know how
knowledge is defined today is we still
have the definition of mister Plato and
that's justified true belief and when
you come to think of it you know we all
know that God exists don't we and we and
there's a lot of people out there who
know that God doesn't exist and so the
question who knows let's get to the
Leonarda Susskind quote what I don't and
I don't try to see it in my head and
trying to explain it to people who don't
have mathematics mathematical background
we get stuck I can't say now close your
eyes and view in your head five
dimensions because I can't do it either
all I can do is say take X Y & Z and add
V and W eventually a person where this
type of mathematical background begins
to develop mathematical intuitions for
things they don't need the same kind of
visualizations so we're stuck needing
mathematics because evolution didn't
equip us to be able to visualize quantum
mechanics it didn't equip us to
visualize 11 dimensional space tax
evolution did this to us
sounds like makes sense to me doesn't it
well what he's saying is we're three
dimensional being stuck in a three
dimensional world with which we are
familiar right and the issue is is there
a four dimensional five six seven ten
twenty six dimensional universe out
there and we cannot see it because we're
stuck in three dimensions like a two
dimensional flat that the lander would
be stuck into that in flattening right
you would not be able to relate to a
three-dimensional solid lab world and
you know they use that analogy to say
why we cannot imagine the fourth
dimension or the four dimensional world
but when you look at what do you mean by
four dimensional what is this space time
for that 4d space time and when you look
at it in more detail you find out that
they're just for number lines that they
use to locate a point within space-time
so it's like
circular argument what is space-time
space-time is an event that can be
located with four number lines right
because they're not even coordinates
within space-time
that's what it that's what space-time is
in physics I mean in mathematics yeah
that it might have all you know they
want to locate a point and label it and
tell me how many coordinates they can
precisely pinpoint it with in space I
think and do whatever they want but they
can't later on extrapolate that and say
okay I'm gonna bend space-time and
that's how we're gonna produce gravity
partly because of one of the other
things I sent you there you know you
need a force to bend space-time for that
you need to know it would be number it's
number 18 you look at number 18 say you
put you gotta push it down you're gonna
push the earth down on the canvas right
and then the question is why doesn't the
earth push it upwards see if they show
this what comes next
if they showed that people would say oh
that's counterintuitive what do you mean
the earth pushes space-time upwards so
they always have you know the earth
pushing the fishnet downwards that's the
physical interpretation they offer and
that's misleading because space-time
should not have any any direction you
know it's very interesting I never
realized this but the idea of stretching
in general relativity is always one
directional it's always stretching down
rather than stretching up we don't have
such a thing as positively spaced
curvature but but the reason for that
let me just address the first part the
reason for that is that a gravity is one
directional you know gravity is always
towards the other object yeah the moon
is attracted towards the Earth and the
earth towards the moon in other words
they're going in one direction and so
you have to explain that direction if
gravity were multi-directional
you know we wouldn't have this this
issue with with us fishnet and yeah I
think there there's a serious problem
with that because you need four
to explain that pushing down on the
fishnet if you're gonna give a physical
interpretation and again you know if
you're pushing down a concept I don't
even know why the fishnet represents
that concept called space-time what you
have is a three-dimensional fish you
really what you have is a
three-dimensional fishnet shown into
that in a two-dimensional image and they
say what we cannot imagine it in four
dimensions but anyway you look at it's a
concept what is space-time time is a
concept
are you gonna use are you gonna take a
three-dimensional rock put it together
with five seconds and create a rock time
what is that what kind of object is that
what sense does that make now you send
us a tesseract see that's supposed to be
four-dimensional according to them what
are we looking at what we're looking at
is a box within another box that's
objectively what's in front of our eyes
and what they do they put it in motion
to incorporate time within that image so
what we're looking at is a photograph of
a movie that's that's what space-time is
a photograph of a movie what you're
seeing is a box through time expanding
and that's what they call space-time
time is a dynamic concept it's not even
a static concept you can't talk about a
four-dimensional tesseract if a
tesseract is supposed to in some way
represent space-time you know it's it's
a dynamic concept I'm not sure what what
is being illustrated here what I see is
kind of a cube just moving into another
cube and extending its borders is that a
four-dimensional space representation
it's supposed to represent the
four-dimensional space they're trying to
present it so that people try to
understand more or less what they're
referring to and what they're saying a
tesseract is actually a box that is
expanding through time and yeah it's a
big problem because it means that this
box is built with time with with
something which is dynamic okay so you
can't really see a tesseract in one
piece because all you would see is
a box inside another box it would be a
three-dimensional image
planted onto a 2-dimensional platform
all right personally my favorite way of
visualizing for this space I'll do it
never led to anything productive in my
head I imagine slices of 3d space
I imagine a cube at T equals zero and
then a cube at T equals one and then a
cube at T equals four yeah it's a
concept again and you know if you look
at some of these other like look at
number 10 there this shows you how these
people are doing yeah they're what
they're doing is they're saying that
mass warps time you know the space time
is that little fishnet there it's
supposed to be a four-dimensional
fishnet of some kind three dimensions of
space plus one of time okay let's even
concede that for the sake of argument
how can mass a concept how can kilograms
way and bend space-time what are we
talking about what what does this have
to do with physics I think we don't know
why but I think it has been measured
that there is a gravity a gravitational
effect on the warping of space and time
am I wrong on this well that's their
physical interpretation but again it
comes back to the wording I mean what do
we mean when we say that we Bend time
forget about space okay will concede
space let's say it faces a physical
object right how can we say that we bent
time how can you bend the concept what
are they bending a second a minute an
hour what maybe it's a calendar maybe to
year that they're bending
what are they bending another one that
means that for whatever reason we can
understand their physical interpretation
because their physical interpretation is
not physical it's it's concepts that
they're bending they're saying we're
bending love if I told you
gravity is the bending of love you would
say well I didn't understand it what do
you mean
if I lose to a highly it would mean that
if I'm close to a highly gravitational
field the woman will take more time to
be ready for sex you know that you can
bend a concept in that you can make it
evolve faster or slower in the case of
the bending of time what is the the
claim is that an observer that is not
subject to the gravitational field
versus one that is subject to the
gravitational field they will have
perceived a flow into the future that is
haider slower or faster that's a
mathematical description perfect
mathematical description we have no
problem with that and we don't care
about that we want to know what the
physical interpretation is of that that
you just said why caught what's the
mechanism that's where we're that's
where we have a problem we do we don't
know that I tend to think that we're
kind of in an elevator advancing toward
the future I like to think of the
universe as a a box that is advancing at
the speed of light into the dimension
that time is but I have no idea if that
is correct it's not correct because that
is not a dimension dimension is length
width and height
that's what I mentioned time has nothing
no relation whatsoever to length width
and height and what they're saying is
space is length width and height and
then we have time and even Hawking
Stephen Hawking would say that there's
no difference between a time any you
know one of these regular dimensions why
because they don't care they're only
looking at numbers and for them they're
all number lines what they've done is
confuse the dimensions of physics length
width and height with the coping with
the number lines of mathematics which is
has no direction and has magnitude and
length width and height are the opposite
they don't have magnitude and you have
not only direction but orthogonality so
there's a big difference between them
and the last number what is it number 20
[ __ ] will sit
sizes that synthesizes the difference
between dimensions of physics and those
of number of mathematics see if that
mentions length width and height a box
that's that's what we say it's three
dimensional that's why we call the three
dimensional to say that something is
four dimensional and by incorporating
time all you're doing you're saying that
the box is moving and so does the you
know that's the tiger become
four-dimensional because it moves
through time you know what are we saying
here are we talking about at a four
dimensional object or are we saying at a
three dimension object is moving through
time you know these are different things
and coordinates are different than the
number lines of mathematics as well and
so our vectors vector is a dynamic
concept we have depth breadth and
elevation those are the names of the
vectors in physics in mathematics they
don't use that they don't have any use
for the qualitative dimensions vectors
and coordinates what they use is number
lines that's all they use a number line
has one thing that is specific to the
two number lines into math and that is
it has no direction time has no
direction what it has is magnitude and
that's where these things different one
is qualitative the other one is
quantitative so the classical physical
answer to these differences between the
spatial dimension and the time dimension
is to give a special property to the
time dimension it's definitely it
behaves differently the time dimension
than the space dimensions but in your
setting how do you define time how do
you understand time time we define as a
comparison of two motions you have to
have a memory device you have to have
recording device in memory you have to
memorize the motion of one compared
against the motion of another object so
the difference between motion and time
that's the first distinction we have to
make motion is
an object that occupies at least two
locations and time is a comparison of
two motions and you need a recording
device you need memory to conceptualize
time you cannot have time without memory
all right very interesting you have sent
us others other images that was relating
to the Einstein's predictions about
gravity and and I think that you've
already mentioned on a previous show
that the verticality of the a Baron or
Uranus what was it it's its orbit was
acting differently no we cannot
extrapolate Einstein's equations to a
three body system we can do with a
two-body system we just have the Sun
weighs down the canvas of space-time
let's let's concede that and then the
earth rolls around that depression find
no problem and we can even do it with a
moon we say okay the Sun weighs down the
canvas of space-time the earth rolls
around and the earth weighs its own
canvas downwards and the moon goes
around the earth so far so good but what
happens when we go to Uranus well we
have Oberon and it doesn't you know the
Uranus does not weigh the campus
downwards your sirness pushes the canvas
outwards for Oberon to go around the
poles and when you go to the system of
pluto and charon what you've got is the
Charon moves towards the Sun and away
from the Sun in other words it's going
towards and away from the Sun around
Pluto and so forth at Pluto would have
to push the canvas side words in the
direction of motion and so you know we
don't have consistency between three
body systems in these three separate
instances in other words the earth with
its moon Uranus with its moon Oberon and
or
any other it's moons and Pluto with its
moon Charon you don't have consists in
anything I didn't know that we add the
three orthogonal positions for orbital
interactions in bodies that rotate
around the Sun yes sir you don't take my
word for it so what is the takeaway from
this you have a better explanation then
then the bending of space-time look how
simple it is okay okay so here's the
earth and here's and my hand will be the
Sun okay think of it a ball here right
so we're attached to the Sun you know
it's very simple to understand what I'm
saying the Sun moves the earth around
because every atom on earth is attached
to every atom of the Sun and likewise
every atom of the moon is attached to
every atom of the earth so it's like the
epicycles that what is it done what was
his name the Greek guy Ptolemy sorry
Tala bacon he wrote in his book he wrote
about the epicycles which is think of it
as a cowboy going around in circles with
his horse and at the same time you know
twirling a lasso over his head that's
essentially what each one of these looks
like from from my perspective in other
words you have the cowboy attached to a
center with a rope and the Rope the
lasso is tied to his hand through
another piece of rope so one what is
twirling around the other guy and if we
look at it that way then if every atom
in the universe is interconnected with
all others then we can understand
gravity very easily because it's a pull
mechanism now we have not something push
earth towards the Sun or a depression
are long you know like a roulette where
the earth goes around the Sun because
there is a depression caused by the Sun
instead of that what we have as a
physical interpretation we have every
atom on earth connected to every atom of
the Sun now we can understand how the
Sun twirls the earth around itself and
the earth twirls the moon around itself
that makes sense it's the rope theory
but then how do we explain the
orthogonal ithi of certain satellites
why is Aaron that way why is Charon that
way well part of it is due to the spin
of those planets if you look at the
spins they are related to the direction
in which the moon's twirl and when you
look at the spins then there's no
mystery because now the Sun twirls Pluto
around in this direction like it does
with all the other planets but Pluto
twirls Charon in the direction of the
Sun because that's the spin so it is the
sense of rotation of the planet that
determines then the satellites direction
I think in most cases we got to look at
each case individually there are other
factors working you know in each one of
these cases but in general yes in
general I would say that if you look at
how the moon's go around the planets we
have to look at in general at the spin
of the planet all right Benna grade was
this all for tonight or did we have
anything else to talk about now the only
thing I wanted to show that if you look
at anything from 11 to 19 these are all
the irrational mechanisms proposed by by
general relativity here you see I put
these walls there because that's the
depression and the question is if there
is a wall of space-time that blocks the
escape of the earth out of the solar
system is that if that's the mechanism
why does the moon go through that wall
and if you look at the next picture the
one about the comet
same thing why does the comment go
through that same wall that prevents the
Earth from moving out of the solar
system and you can say that also about
astronauts and other like you know we
sent the rover to Mars and the question
is how did the rover get to Mars if
there's this wall of space that prevents
you know the rover firm from pre-med
first the earth from leaving the solar
system but it doesn't prevent the rover
from going through that same wall we
have to explain that difference it seems
your question is that they don't get
trapped in that local area because there
is on top of this representation there
is an initial speed the comet is coming
into this hole at a certain speed that
will allow it to escape it eventually
well all I'm saying is I'm trying to
illustrate the problem the problem is
that if the depression caused by the Sun
in space time is what prevents the Earth
from leaving the solar system if that's
the physical interpretation then the
question is why can things go back and
forth you know into into the sollars
into the Sun like in this case the comet
or why does the moon go through that
same wall I mean we have to explain that
difference why can the moon go through
space time and not the earth it's like
if the earth was a roulette ball right
and the earth cannot leave the roulette
right because you drove it around in it
it's going around the depression well
why can the moon go into the roulette
and back out you know where has it why
does it have its own roulette
yeah I get what you're saying but I
don't think it's a problem because I
think that ultimately it's the sum of
influence in other words the moon is
attracted to the Sun on average and it's
essentially the pair of the moon and the
earth that's attracted to the Sun but
this bending is not enough to keep the
moon from being in France by the
depression of the earth itself we're
saying we have a depression inside a
depression I guess that's what you're
saying yeah and we have
depression inside a depression why does
the moon go through the depression of
the Sun cause it because there should be
a bigger wall caused by the Sun than by
the earth the earth has a little
depression does the Sun has a big
depression and that's not count all the
other planets in between and beyond
right well not if we not if we include
the distance the Sun is very far
yeah but the Sun can be very far but we
cannot leave the solar system according
to general activity because there's a
wall of space-time that is bent right
behind us are the skin of the planet of
ours planet is rubbing against this
space-time that doesn't allow us to
leave the solar system that's the
physical interpretation and so this has
to be a major role this is this is
bigger than the Berlin wall you know
what I'm saying here and and here you
have you have this little moon going
around the little depression of the
earth and it's just going in through
there that Suns depression back out it
just goes around you know to break
through the wall and back out you would
think that the depression wall of the
Sun is much bigger than the depression
wall caused by the earth
all right personally I don't see it as a
while I see it as a force a tendency the
more you are into the depression the
stronger the force is but it seems that
the earth is at the distant enough
position from the Sun to just have an
equilibrium where it keeps its distance
away from the Sun in a stable fashion
year after year there's lots of
reactions from the crowd simce says what
will happen to ropes if the expansion of
the universe exceeds the speed of light
on there are some models of the future
well we can't talk about the extension
of the universe because the word
universe is a concept universes is a
concept that includes two you could call
entities or Thor words concepts that are
treated as entities one is space and the
other one is matter okay so we have all
these atoms in the in the so called
universe and space is part of the word
universe so universe is
equal to space and atoms and to say that
the universe expands or the universe the
stairs of that that's irrational we have
to say what are we talking about we're
talking about the atoms expanding
getting away from each other are we
talking about the expansion of space a
concept which means exactly nothing
vacuum emptiness what is it stretching
what is it that is expanding are we
talking about the atoms or space all
right the r-word being asked a question
that is outside of your domain of
specialty says bill how did the name
their toes disappear you did that was
nothing wearing it yeah I go to see they
say that first the official version or
the most popular version today they
intermarried with us that's that's how
they say we disappeared they disappeared
because they intermarried with us what
happened was supposedly we were a much
larger population and intermarried with
us and slowly they whittled away and we
remained and that's why we still have
like two to three percent DNA belonged
to Neanderthal in our blood
the first problem with that theory is
that officially from what from the
record okay the Nano cells have been
shown to have disappeared 40,000 years
ago they can't find anymore of their
technology after 40,000 years after
visiting many several of their sites in
Europe right the first human skeleton
that appears in Europe which is in
Romania appears 35,000 years ago so if
we just go by the objectively by the
record the Neanderthal disappeared 5,000
years before humans entered Europe and
that to me makes sense because I think
it was the Neanderthals that kept humans
out of Europe and it's when the
Neanderthals disappeared that the you
humans could finally enter Europe now
how did they disappear I'm saying all
species disappeared in a background
extinction in two ways says he
mechanisms that create their extinction
this happens to all of speed all species
plants and animals and to us it's
happening right now and that is first we
lose our genetic diversity until there
is none we can't create new genetic
diversity we can only lose it okay and
that's a long story but that's the first
factor the second factor is or at the
end of the or close to the end of a
species lifetime the population pyramid
over terms and the in other words more
individuals of that population grow
older and fewer are younger until you
know the whole pyramid overturns and you
can show that with a little piece of
bread that you leave on the table
overnight probably a little longer and
it turns green and all these bacteria
you know they just multiply until they
cover the whole world in which they live
which is that piece of bread and then
after that it just decays until you get
extinction news there was a news item on
this the National Post publishes there
used to be nine species of human what
happened to them myself and again I'm
saying they disappear all by themselves
we didn't kill anybody we didn't cause
their extinction no species causes the
extinction of another what happens is
all species implode they implode because
their genetic diversity disappears it
has to unless it can create new
environmental conditions and that only
happens at the beginning of a species
lifetime when it branches out from the
mother or the main branch of the main
trunk okay so they encounter new new
conditions that's when they create
genetic diversity genetic diversity
eventually winds down through a series
of thousands of years of bottlenecks and
what is it founders effect so you have a
series of is it
of bottlenecks where there's a disease
or whatever that causes the lots to die
and from there you have a founders in
fact that now creates the next
generation we have this successively and
that streamlines that you're the
genetics of that species unless it can
mate with something else it's an
interesting view I think that you are
Hal I think very important processes of
evolution that tend to be not
necessarily this customer in-stream that
being said I think you're a little too
radical
when you say species don't cause the
extinction of other species I mean you
can certainly make a scenario in which a
species takes the ecology of another
species and keeps it from exploiting it
well you're saying competition I don't
think has anything at all to do with
extinction
neither xt their competition neither
climate change none of those things have
any effect on species it's it's just
that in this day and age we have all
these things like climate change which
are so deep in our hearts and in the
news and everything and everybody says
oh climate change i say it's got nothing
at all to do with extinction extinction
comes when genetic diversity disappears
and population pyramid overturns very
interesting as ur patter says light fire
electricity magnetic attraction are
these physical objects that exist
according to this definition of
existence are ropes
physical objects that exist good
question good question
atoms we can say exists because we could
say they have their objects and they
have location and every time we always
use the word location we refer to
objects that we could see and touch and
feel it cetera we can't touch the rope
we cannot mother nature was wise in her
or God or whoever created that is right
it was very wise because they made the
rope intangible and unseeable okay so we
cannot see or touch the rope therefore
we cannot prove the existence of the
rope by going to the lab and say let me
experiment to see if the rope exists no
you have to sit back and define the word
exists first and then conceptualize
that's the way to reach this problem and
of course if you go out there and say
well how am I going to define the word
exists well I'm gonna define it as a
physical object okay it's gotta be an
object and then it's gotta have location
and the question is does the Rope have
location and the problem there is that
we've always measured or or
conceptualize location only between
atoms between things we never
conceptualize it between that which we
could not see so if you have seen two
atoms and you can't see the Rope between
it you can't touch it as far as you're
concerned there's empty space there and
now under the Rope model distance is
length the length of a rope between two
atoms so so we don't have empty space or
Paris between two atoms what we have is
a rope and if we're gonna limit the word
location to atoms and above then the
rope under that definition does not
exist other than that it's an object and
again the the bottom be the ultimate
hypothesis there's a single thread in
the entire universe that converts into
atoms and ropes
atoms rose atom droves it's a single
thread if we could untie it all
completely and he enters the night
exists well for that it would have to
have location location with respect to
what and again it's a question of
definitions quote of the night you can't
touch the Rope nutri Nereid fractal it
says what is the different of using math
or words in a sentence what makes one
better than the other words seem to just
be adding an unnecessary layer to please
emotional needs
if space-time doesn't exist how can two
objects share the same space only if
they are two at two different time can
the Rope break a lot of questions there
let's go one one by one the first one go
with the first one again
the first one is is there an advantage
using words over mat because you are
often criticizing math but you are using
your own English Shakespearean maths
here yeah Matthews with quantities with
numbers and physics deals with
qualitative aspects and with mechanisms
so there is a difference between saying
well what if we just do numbers well
then all you're doing is describing
you're not explaining and explain
explanation is a little different than a
description that's that's the first
answer the first question what was the
second question here the second question
is about objects being at the same place
at different times how does how is it
allowed and can two objects be at the
same place at the same time two objects
cannot be at first of all all objects
are in the present there's no such thing
as the past there's no such thing as the
future like in general relativity every
object simply exists exists is not a
verb exists as an adjective you know
what we're saying is simply it has
location with respect to other objects
and that's in the present it's in a
cross-section of time you can say any
cross-section of time if you can
visualize that in other words we take a
single slice of so-called space-time and
that's what exists what exists at that
point therefore two objects cannot be a
two separate piece of time periods
they're all in the same time period
every atom is in the universe is a
single cross-section of time now can two
objects be at the same place at the same
time no not in not in in under the rope
model and I'm talking about atoms okay
so two atoms cannot be at the same place
at the same time as in quantum mechanics
even worse two objects two atoms cannot
be or one atom cannot be at two places
at the same time which is also what
quantum mechanics says they call it the
was it forgot the word again I think
I've heard this the the Pauli exclusion
principle I think it was the Pauli
exclusion
yeah but that again that was derived
from having electrons in the same orbit
in other words uh it comes from the
analysis of the atom but then they
extrapolated that to all particles and
they say because these particles that's
why we don't have any big pictures of
any of the particles in the quantum
model you're the standard model you
won't find a single particle you find is
descriptions like so much mass so much
energy you know that kind of stuff but
you will not find a picture and why
because they've never seen a single
particle these are assumptions and
people think that particles have been
proven and they have not been proven
it's it's just an assumption that though
the university is run by particles and
when you put the rope model obviously
clashes against you know the notion that
there are partly at discrete particles
and everything's United all atoms are
interconnected all right one last
question base de volver says in a past
interview bill said that there will be
no new technology and that the cell
phone is speak technology for our
species that is does he still have this
view cell phone is not an invention the
last invention was the computer that was
what 1980s I worked on and that kind of
stuff you know I did a lot of work on
chips and so on after that everything
was it was simply a mixture of different
inventions in other words what is a cell
phone cell phone is a television a
computer a phone and who knows what else
all-in-one and portable you know that's
that's what we wanted that that's what
we always wanted I mean if then the
other cells would have had that they
would have loved it you know this hell
now I should talk to the other guy in
the other cave and so on right so that
is that is the ultimate invention but
it's not an invention it's just a what
they did was
incorporate all these sort of all these
inventions that we already had we
already had the Taliban we had the TV we
had the computer they said how do we put
that all into one and that took us but
about 40 years and now we have and
that's I think maybe the one of the last
really important not inventions they're
they're developments that they make of
inventions they simply put them together
you know these are not inventions all
right bid it was a great pleasure
talking to you I have some solo subject
news to do so I will say goodbye to you
and let's talk again in the future did
you say goodbye or good riddance
continue continue planning your
subversion of science in solo and we'll
have you again to continue to combat the
mainstream position of physics oh god
bill gayde you know I would like to help
him I would like him to to to accept
that there are some things in physics
that are valid but there's no getting
into Bill Gates Brian he only goes by
the Rope there's no way to take him out
of it but Neutron